history being made at the democratic
national convention did you stay up late
we did so we've got it covered in case
you did not senator kamala harris
officially
became the first black woman ever on a
major party's presidential ticket
after formally accepting her party's
nomination for vice president of the
united states
tonight also saw former president barack
obama delivering a
sharp rebuke of president trump he
called on all americans to vote
and said democracy itself is at stake
in this election ed o'keefe is in
wilmington delaware where harris made
her speech ed good morning
good morning anthony on what is said to
be the biggest day in the political life
of joe biden we'll get to that in a
moment but we begin
with senator harris who became just the
third woman ever
to accept the vice presidential
nomination and as she did
she remembered her mother she probably
could have never imagined
that i would be standing before you now
and
speaking these words
i accept your nomination for vice
president
of the united states of america in an
acceptance speech unlike any ever given
before
california senator kamala harris shared
her family's history
recalling her parents activism and what
she called a stroller's eye view
of the civil rights movement she raised
us to be
proud strong black women and she raised
us
to know and be proud of our indian
heritage
the senator who has faced criticism from
progressives for her past
prosecutorial record spoke frankly about
the ongoing national reckoning on race
and how minorities are
disproportionately affected by the
pandemic
there is no vaccine for racism
we've got to do the work
for george floyd for brianna taylor
for the lives of too many others to name
and she pinned the blame squarely
on president trump donald trump's
failure of leadership
has cost lives and livelihoods
donald trump hasn't grown into the job
because he can't
former president barack obama delivered
the most stinging rebuke of a sitting
president
by a former president in modern history
for close to four years now he has shown
no
interest in putting in the work no
interest in finding common ground
no interest in using the awesome power
of his office
to help anyone but himself and his
friends
no interest in treating the presidency
as anything but one more reality show
that he can use
to get the attention he craves speaking
from the museum of the american
revolution in philadelphia
he spoke poignantly about americans once
marginalized because of who they were
if anyone had a right to believe that
this democracy did not work
and could not work it was those
americans
our ancestors at times the former
president almost pleaded with americans
to take action do not let them take away
your power do not let them take away
your democracy so did many of the women
who spoke
including house speaker nancy pelosi and
mr trump's 2016 opponent hillary clinton
recalled what can happen when people
don't turn out to vote and don't forget
joe and kamala can win by 3 million
votes
and still lose take it from me
so we need numbers overwhelming so trump
can't sneak
or steal his way to victory
someone who was watching closely last
night perhaps no surprise president
trump
who fired off several angry tweets with
false and misleading claims
some democrats immediately said the
president was in essence proving mr
obama's point
that he's unfit to serve now tonight
attention turns
to joe biden here at what's called the
chase center on the riverfront looks a
little bit like a home depot but we
promise this is a
event center that actually can hold a
television studio that democrats have
built
for the event very similar to what
kamala harris spoke from last night
biden has been seeking the presidency in
one way or another for almost
50 years and will accept the nomination
tonight on the third try
of course this isn't at all what we were
expecting to cover we were supposed to
be in the battleground state of
wisconsin
biden was supposed to speak in front of
thousands tonight
he'll speak from his hometown a city
that has a senator he came home to
almost every night tony
yeah the highly anticipated speech and
we'll have to see if the current
occupant of the oval office will be
tuning in along with all of the rest of
us ed thank you very much